[Music]
in episode three of Monarch the legacy
of monsters we got to see a soft reboot
of the incident at the bikini atal
whereby the US military along with the
founders of the organization of Monarch
lured in Godzilla into the islands and
nuked him with a hydrogen bomb which was
then covered up as nuclear testing Cod
Nam Castle Bravo in brief moments we got
to see Godzilla as he was in 1954 and
dare I say he bore a great resemblance
to the 2014 version but also slightly
different most notably his size and
slight changes in his dorsal plates so
here in this video we will analyze the
footage and estimate the size of the Big
G as he was in that year 70 years before
the events of the mut battle let's get
to it so how do we go about an
estimating his size first we need a good
reference point which can be
extrapolated then later the best way to
do this is by carefully examining the
footage of the structures and people
seen in the Bikini atols before Godzilla
was next to the nuke so the best way
here is to take a look at something that
is both seen next to a person and then
again next to Godzilla and what else
than the bomb platform in one of the
scenes we see a US Marine or maybe just
a US Army Personnel that was next to the
tower holding the Castle Bravo nuke so
we all know that an average US soldier
would be almost 6 ft tall or 1.8 m give
or take a few inches by this we can
place uh 6 ft tall lines one on top of
another to get the height of the bomb
platform this gives us an approximate
height of 9 M or 30 ft so now that we
have that let's take a look at Godzilla
so in this episode Godzilla was clearly
firstly seen as swimming towards the
island with only his dorsal plates being
visible above the water and then he
stood up and was clearly visible ible in
the distance before the bomb exploded
and yeah he was standing in the Coast
with a bit of his body his feet
submerged underwater don't worry we got
that covered too Godzilla here was
supposed to be chasing the shinamura
Titan to the islands and both of them
were LED in to be killed but that story
has now been red gone for Better or For
Worse we shall see anyway here in this
scene we have Godzilla roaring and just
beneath him in the beach was the same
bomb platform so now let's do our Magic
We Know by the early estimation that the
bomb platform was 9 M or 30 ft tall so
now we can extrapolate to get an
approximate number of bomb platforms to
fit the size of the Big G so to get to
the surface height excluding the
submerged body part we have less than
nine bomb platforms which puts his
height here above the sea level at less
than 260 or 270 ft so to get to the
exact height we have to bring in the
full body design and place it next to
the image and now with this here we get
his height to be less than 11 platforms
but as you can see there is still a
little bit of the lines extending Beyond
on each end on top of and below so now
let's put Godzilla the design next to
the line starting from the bottom uh
counting the lines we get the Gman to be
a bit more than 10 Platforms in height
which translates to more than 90 M or a
bit more than 295 ft thus rounding this
off to be 300 ft or 91.5 M tall and that
is the 1954 size now let's put him in
comparison with the future versions as
you know Godzilla when he first appeared
in the monsterverse in 2014 was already
bigger than most of the past
incarnations he was 355 ft tall or 108 M
this makes him 70 years older than this
1954 Godzilla in Monarch and also 55 ft
or 17 M taller now after this battle
with the muta prime he changed
drastically he developed larger more
Maple Leaf shaped dorsal plates and
increased in size in his kotm
Incarnation and GVK he was stated to be
almost 100 20 M or 393 ft tall this
makes the current king of the monsters
in 2024 80 years older and 93 ft or 28 M
taller than the 1954 version to be more
precise the 1954 bikini atol Godzilla
was the same as the female Muto in
height now let's talk a little bit on
the changes of the dorsal plate designs
and then come to a close the Monarch
Godzilla of 1954 had the same basic
dorsal plate designs as the 2014 Gary
Goji but they appear to be shorter and
less impressive as Godzilla had no
deadly fights in between these years it
made no sense that the dorsal plates
would have to change and they should
remain the same but I guess the Castle
Bravo nuke would give Godzilla a huge
power up with all the radiation emitted
in the blast and it's like the
equivalence of pumping steroids into the
body to unnaturally speed up the growth
of muscles I'm guessing that this bomb
which is 10 times more powerful than the
one Ser zawa used to revitalize Godzilla
in his layer in kotm this bomb Castle
Bravo would give him the necessary boost
to grow in size from 300 ft to 355 ft
and the blast might have overloaded or
damage the dosel plates as well a bit
you know to push them to grow bigger and
become more like the 2014 OG design so
yeah that's it we have come to the end
of this size estimation video of
Godzilla if you like it then watch this
other one as well and if you're more
interested in other movie monsters and
creatures then check out our Channel
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam